أود أن أشكر مضيفنا السعودي
لدعوته الولايات المتحدة للانضمام إلى هذه
القمة
وعلى كرم الضيافة الذي استقبلنا جميعًا
تغير كثيرًا منذ أن زرت
هذه المنطقة عندما خدمت كنائب
رئيس الولايات المتحدة
على المسرح العالمي و  في
الشرق الأوسط
حول العالم ، نشهد جهودًا
لتقويض النظام القائم على القواعد من
خلال الإجراءات الصينية القسرية المتزايدة
في منطقة المحيط الهادئ وخارجها
مع حرب روسيا الوحشية وغير المبررة
ضد هذا الجار في أوكرانيا
مع أنشطة إيران المزعزعة للاستقرار
هنا في الوسط.  في الشرق ، شهدنا أيضًا
تغييرات
حاسمة لأول مرة منذ 11 سبتمبر
، يزور رئيس أمريكي هذه
المنطقة دون مشاركة القوات الأمريكية
في القتال ومهمة قتالية
في المنطقة ،
سنحترم دائمًا شجاعة
وأنانية نكران الذات في
تضحيات  الأمريكيون الذين خدموا
بما فيهم ابني الرائد بو بايدن كانوا
متمركزين في العراق لمدة عام